Kurt on the other hand kind of he held
that movie together when they fired the
director and brought George in and and
and Kurt's a wonderful guy he's a great
great personalities he's fun he's got a
great laugh uh obviously a wonderful
actor has been a movie star since he was
10. you always hear about people talking
about uh actors who
um young actors growing up in the
business they're always get all [__]
up or whatever not Kurt Kurt you know
Kurt yeah who he was yeah I guess so I
mean I it you know that's not not part
of my life but uh there's a there's a
part of me like you know when I go on
set you want the other person you want
the people to be oh this can be fun this
is gonna be but it sounds to me like
this movie was just like don't expect to
make friends do your [__] part I'm
there to make a movie to be great and if
they don't want to be like that that's
not going to affect my performance yeah
well they don't you know I don't here's
the thing about making movies it's a
collaborative thing and I I don't I I'm
not gonna do anything I'm not going to
try to undercut anybody and you heard
Robert Patrick talking about some movie
he was on where some actor was trying to
undercut him I think we know who's
talking about right but you know I I
never I've never in my life thought like
uh you know if I stood over here maybe I
could take something away from this I've
never done that nor do I ever see
anybody do it to me and if I even think
that you know somebody does their off
camera so they're not really paying
attention you're not doing their off
camera that well I'm just like [__] you
I don't need you to do off-camera I'd
rather you you know if somebody's just
kind of a lot of times off camera I'll
just go like just you move out of the
way and I'll do it to air I'd rather
have a piece of tape
exactly which is better performance
because they're not giving me anything
and I don't want to be distracted by
their [__] and with me with
distraction and you hear people uh
you're in my eye line can everybody move
on my eyeline I'm like [__] you get in
my eye line do jumping jacks behind the
the Jesus